hello everyone and welcome back to the
fourth game of the Champions Chester
finals Magnus Carlson versus Wesley so
it all looked like Magnus was going to
take an easy win in the second match
after he won the first game but then
Wesley retaliated in the second game
with the black pieces uh game three was
a fairly calm draw and now this is game
for Magnus is white Wesley is black uh
not going to say anything more but you
guys will love this game let's check it
out and um a fair warning it is a it is
a very short one so Magnus opened with
D4 we have Knight to F6 C4 E6 and now
Knight to F3 we have Pawn to D5 and the
Queen's Gambit declined is on the board
we have Knight to C3 and Wesley looks
for a win with the semit tarash he plays
Pawn to C5 C captures on D5 by Magus and
now uh top moves here are Knight
captures and pawn captures but Pawn
captures on D4 is the third most popular
option and it is a very sharp one and
this is what Wesley is hoping um that
that will maybe get him some winning
chance with the black pieces so Magnus
plays Queen captures we have e captures
on D5 and now E4 going for the early
Queen trade uh Wesley goes forward D
captures on e4 Queen captures on d8 and
now King captures on d8 Knight to G5
putting pressure on that F7 Pawn going
for the fork and Bishop to E6 and while
Knight captures on E6 is pretty much an
automatic because it is the top engine
move uh it is also the most analyzed
line and of course Magnus knows that
Wesley knows that so he plays Bishop to
D2 and it has only been played once H in
2019 rajabu played against yuran P
forest and their game ended in a draw
but here we have uh in that game
continued with Bishop to B4 by Ordon uh
but here Wesley plays Knight B to D7 and
it is now already as of move 10 that we
have a completely new game so okay
Magnus recaptures see Knight captures on
uh E4 we have Knight captures Knight
captures and now Pawn to H6 and already
a slight imprecision by Wesley that
Magnus takes advantage of masterfully
believe it or not you have to take away
the G5 Square from wi pieces but by
playing Pawn to F6 uh Now by playing
Pawn to H6 Magnus plays Bishop to C3 and
you can see how Pawn to F6 would also
take away the G5 Square for example from
the Knight H but also now if you play F6
then you really weaken the light squares
here however you're going to have to
play it at some point if you want to get
any sort of development with black here
so Wesley first plays Rook to C8 we have
B to D3 and now he goes for Pawn to F6
now how can Magnus take advantage of
this setup uh he castles and now King to
E8 wasley knows that of course a rook
will come uh to D1 so it's best to hide
the king as quickly as possible uh
Magnus goes Bishop to E2 to have some
Bishop to H5 action perhaps so how do
you conter this well you could play King
to F7 to have G6 Ready Or you could play
H5 right away but that kind of further
weakens your king side so Wesley goes
King to F7 and now Pawn to F4 taking
away the E5 Square from the Knight and
also having F5 ready so Bishop to C5
developing with check King to H1 sorry
not King to H1 Magnus captured the
bishop Knight captures on C5 as Bishop
to C5 was an imprecision by Wesley but
Magnus does not take advantage of it
Rook captures on C5 and now Magnus just
played Rook a to D1 the key move here is
Bishop to D4 and not just because you're
attacking the pawn even if let's say
Rook to A5 is played uh Rook a to C1 and
now Rook coming to C7 cannot be
prevented uh it's just um well maybe
even close to a winning Advantage for
white due to the exposed black king
however after Rook captures on C5 Rook 8
to D1 was played and now Knight to B6
now Bishop to D4 will not be as potent
but it's still the strongest move so
Magnus plays it uh Rook to A5 now
putting some pressure on that A2 pawn
and now Pawn to B4 this is a beautiful
move and uh I know that I always
emphasize on how strong B4 is but here
is just uh it's just almost crushing
because if you capture The Rook if Rook
captures the pawn here uh look at what
happens Bishop to H5 check and now how
do you defend you don't really gain
anything by moving the king and if you
play G6 uh then comes F5 and now Bishop
captures Rook captures okay you have to
win back your piece otherwise you're
just down material and now Rook captures
an F6 with check and it doesn't matter
where you go to if you go here then just
a nice check will cost you The Rook uh
if you try King to E7 then Rook to E1
with check forces the king to the D5
King D7 Rook F7 check again H picks up
the The Rook on h8 so Wesley cannot take
the pawn he brings the Rook back Rook to
D5 and now Bishop to F3 going after the
rook and now Wesley's last chance is to
move the Rook back Rook to D7 Rook to d8
but he persists he plays Rook to B5 and
his position is now dead lost feel free
to pause the video andn win the
Champions Chester finals for Magnus
while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on uh
finding this brilliancy and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Bishop to C5 no doubt you found that
because you see that Bishop to E2 is a
huge threat uh and not one that is
easily parried uh now how do you save
The Rook uh it's not uh not easy for
example even if you play Bishop to C4
which uh takes away the diagonal from
the from the white Bishop still doesn't
matter just Rook F to E1 and what do you
play here Rook to E7 is the threat
there's just no good way to to counter
this if you go Rook to E8 then a nice
Bishop to H5 check again wins the game
G6 you will just capture on E8 or you
could capture on G6 and then take the
Rook doesn't really matter if captures
Bishop G6 check look at the beautiful
Bishop pair uh The Rook controlling the
D5 so the only thing you can do here is
block with the bishop Bishop F7 but now
Rook E1 check and the King cannot keep
defending the bishop King will have to
move you will take the bishop and you're
just up a full piece of course
completely winning so uh Wesley figured
okay I can't really do that I will have
to give up the exchange here he played
Knight to A4 and now comes Bishop to E2
going after the Rook as now the Knight
no longer defends the C4 Square Rook
captures on C5 B captures on C5 and now
Knight to C3 sort of trying to win back
at least something but Bishop to H5 with
check he does go for G6 but now Rook to
D3 that's how he gets out of this mess
uh Bishop to C4 skewering the Rooks here
but it doesn't matter Rook to D7 with
check King to E6 and now Rook to D6 with
check King to F7 and here Rook to C1
attacking the rook and the bishop here
Knight the E4 was played trying to win
back the exchange but here Magnus just
played Rook to D4 and he was in this
position on move 31 that Wesley so
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so really really a
brutal game uh you can see that they've
spent a lot of time especially Magnus he
ended the game with 16 seconds on the
clock but even if Wesley tried to take
advantage of that there's really nothing
he can do like the bishop is hanging the
Knight is hanging even if play some like
let's say Bishop captur on A2 and hope
maybe to capture the bishop here Magnus
can just bring the bishop back attack
then Knight and if you defend it just a
nice Rook D7 check will ensure you a
pass Pawn you'll play Rook captur on B7
and now you're up the exchange the pass
C Pawn is marching forward some uh moves
might be some like Bishop D5 going after
the Rook C6 and now you're going to play
Rook to C8 of course to try and stop the
pawn uh but now you go after the
kingside pawns If you defend then you
capture the A7 Pawn as well and that's
pretty much it Rook captures on C6 will
be played but after all is said and done
uh this this uh again goes after the
bishop now you cannot move the bishop
you will lose the bishop and that's
pretty much it uh you're going to be up
uh up a full rook and of course
completely winning so Wesley saw this
and after Rook D4 he just resigned so a
tough tough loss for Wesley especially
after winning game two with the black
pieces if you haven't seen it it's the
previous video really a brutal game you
guys will enjoy that one if you haven't
seen it uh but yeah Magnus wins and
there was a lot on the line here not
just the title of the winner of the
Champions Chester finals or the entire
Champions Chester but also uh the winner
gets $200,000 and the second place is
$100,000 so quite quite a money
difference there and this is magnus's
third Champions Chester finals title in
a row he won 2021 2022 and now he wins
Champion Chester
2023 uh what what are you going to do
he's just uh you know he's just a very
very good at chess uh so yeah that
concludes our short coverage of the
Champions Chester finals hope you guys
enjoyed it we're probably going to look
into the chenai master some other
tournaments that are happening uh all
around the world do use hashtag
suggestion if you have a nice game that
you would like me to cover uh but we
will focus on who will qualify for the
candidates tournament will it be lineer
Dominguez will it be will GES and Arjun
have something to say about that will
par makulu maybe have something to say
about that uh it's still it's still very
early and anything can happen and after
that of course we go into the into the
big event of the year the world rapid
and Blitz championship ship so that's
pretty much what we have in store for
for the end of the year and especially
you know whatever you guys suggest if
it's a good game I will cover it uh use
that hashtag suggestion as much as
possible uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it and like I said the
short coverage of the Champions Chester
finals uh I would like to thank Sam's
giant tortois farm the Night Before
Christmas good luck on law school finals
KV Benjamin hyberger and elf on a shelf
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and do check them out
they're very nice especially the the
last game Wesley won uh I will see you
soon and uh have an excellent rest of
your
day